[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في هذه الحلقه من محاور محاور
اليوم نطرحها مع المفكر واستاذ الفلسفه في
جامعه الرباط والمدير المعهد الاكاديمي
للفنون محمد نور الدين
الفلسفي في كتاب النهضه المعلقه صوره
الاخر همم
الغرب وفي السنوات الاخيره يبدو انك منشغل
بمساله الصوره
كان صور الوجود قبل كان المعرفه الصوره
لماذا هذا الانشغال او هذا القلق من
الصوره
لانه بكل بساطه الصوره
اكتسحت المخيله الجماعي والمخيله
الانسانيه منذ قرون ولكن لسيما بعد اكتشاف
الفوتوغرافيه والسينما والتلفزيون وكل ما
تمخض عن هذه
المجالات من اكتشافات وتحولات وبالتالي
صوره اصبحت منا هي موضوع لنا وايضا نحن
موضوع لهذه الصوره وبالتالي اصبحت همم
قضيه فكريه كبرى
كل مجالات البحث والتفكير اصبحت تهتم بهذه
القضيه نظرا لتداعيتها الوجود والاجتماعيه
والسيكولوجيه والوجدانيه وغيرها على
الانسان اولا كاسان كذت وايضا على النوع
العلاقات التفاعليه التي تحصل ما بين
الذات وبين الاخر وايضا تاثير هذه الصور
على الثقافات وعلى المجتمعات ادخلتنا
مباشره الاستاذه فيها في المحور الاساسي
لهذه الحلقه حول اشكاليه الصوره في الفكر
المعاصر
[موسيقى]
عندما نقرا ما كتبته حول الصوره نشعر بنوع
من القلق من طغيان الصوره في الحياه بشكل
عام في الحياه اليوميه لماذا قال
مصدر القلق
ان هذا الموضوع موضوع الصوره
وانعدام الفهم يتصاعد
بفضلي وبسبب هذه التحولات التكنولوجيا
وبالتالي
السياحي للصوره تجد
منها وعلى القبض على مضامينها وابعادها
وخلفياتها وايضا عن همم الرهانات التي
يشتغل او تشتغل مختلف اشكال السلط عليها
من اجل التاثير على الادميرها وعلى
الاذهان وعلى الانسان وعلى المجتمع من هنا
همم بدون بانه كلما حاولنا الاقتراب من
فهمها والتمكن منها كل ما اتت 9 عناصر
جديده جعلتنا همم
نعجز امام التمكن منها بالرغم من
المجهودات الكبيره التي نجد من حيث البحث
والتفكير والنظر للاقتراب من بعض هذه
المكونات التي تشكل هذا الذي نسميه
بالصوره هل اليوم يعني يمكن الحديث عنهم
تشويش على النظر من همم جراء هذا الاغراء
بالصور
يعني صعوبه تحديد موقف من الوجوه من كل
لا الان همم نحن همم معرضين همم كل اشكال
ان همم احد في هذه الكتب حول الصوره لكل
اشكال الاشتياح التي
تمارسها صور مختلفه اشكال الصور لان
الصوره هي صور لا يمكن ان نختزل الصوره في
معنى واحد ابتداء من الفوتوغرافيه الى
التلفزيون الى
السينما الى التشكيل الى كل المستندات لا
يكونلوجيه التي همم يكون وراءها انتاج ما
نسميه الصور الى الصور الذهنيه التي
نصنعها على مستوى المتخيل وعلى مستوى
الانتاج الفكري الفكر ليس بعيدا عن الثوار
وليس بعيدا عن المخيله وبالتالي فاننا نحن
همم معرضين لهذا ال- المد ال- الهائل الذي
بالخصوص في 20 سنه الاخيره اصبح
السياحيا وكبيرا جدا على
كيس وعلى الادراك وعلى ايضا درجات
الانتباه ربما سنعود الى هذه المساله فيما
بعد هل يعني يمكن التحدث عن فكره بصري
يمكن حديث عن فكر بصري وكيف يمكن همم
للفكر المدون ان صح التعبير الفكره الخاصه
التنوير اللي احنا محتاج اليه ان يجد
مكانا له في هذا همم
حينما نتحدث عن الفكر نحن لا نميز ما
بيننا وما هو غير تنويه الفكر البصري هو
الذي يشتغل على الانتاج البصري بكل
المستندات التي تعمل على خلق هذا الذي
يسمى بالكلوجيه وبالتالي من دول اربع بنات
من الاجتهادات داخل
الدراسات التي تتخذ من سوء الفوتوغرافيه
التلفزيون سينما وغير والان
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
هو الذي يعمل جهد المستطاع على الامام
بالمعاني الكبرى التي تحملها او يحملها
هذا هذا هذه المستندات التقنيه او هذه
المنتجات للصوره هل هي كثافه هذه الصوره
تخلق نوع من الواقع الافتراضي او الموازن
ام هو نفس الواقع المرتبط بالوجود بالذات
الذي يعبر عنه بهذا الشكل همم
همم نحن نعيش في مدن ونعيش في عالم
يصعب ان نفرق فيه ما بين ما وواقعه
حتى المدينه اصبحت العباره عن الفضاءات
للفرجه للصور وللمجلات
والاشهارات لوحات الاشهاريه الى اخره نحن
لم نعد نفرق بالضروره ما بين هدينا
المستويين وراسيما
مع الانترنت
الى ابعاده الافتراضيه وبالتالي لم يعد
هناك كبرى اللهم الا اذا تمكننا من ان
نقيم المسافه ما بين الامرين ما بين
الواقع حينما نريد ادركه وما بين
الافتراضي حينما نريد ان نصنعها المعاني
طيب كيف يمكن مواجهه هذا الامر
بعقليه يمكن القول نقديه مثلا يعني كيف
يمكن تطوير هذا همم يعني اذا كنا نتحدث عن
فكر بصري بهذه الطريقه كيف يمكن قراءته بع
نقديه هو اساس الفكر ما نسميه الفكر
البصري وهو بالدرجه الاولى في النقدي اي
انه يدعو الى استنهاض كل ملكات الانسان
سواء كان عقلا او مخيله او احساسا او
ادراكا او اي شيء ممكن للانسان ان يعبئه
من اجله ان يجد ذاته داخل هذا العالم
المترابط
المستويات الواقعيه او افترادي وبالتالي
الصناعه او انتاج هذا الذي تسميه بالمسافه
النقديه يفترض مجموعه من العوامل اولها
الوعي برهانات هذا الذي نعيشه
ثانيا قدرات المؤسسات سواء العائله او
المدرسه او الاعلام او المجتمع في رومته
بان ينتج بعض ما يمكن تسميته عناصر
المقاومه وعناصر
الصيانه ذاتيه هذه الامور السلبيه التي
اصبحت طاغيه على الاحاسيس وعلى الوجدان
وعلى الوعي الانساني طبعا تعتبر في مكان
الماء ان الحواس والجسد اليوم هي التي
تؤثر على عمليه الادراك بينما في فتره
سابقه خاصه همم ديكارت يمكن الحديث عن
العقلانيه اكثر بمعنى كيف يمكن الفاصل
يمكن مقاربه الواقع اليوم الذي نتحدث عن
واقع الصوره من خلال الحواس في الجسد واي
مكان للقراءه العقلانيه
مساله التمييز ما بين العقل والحواس هم
بالعقل والمخيله انتهتامت
طنط ادخل مخيله كجزء اساسي في عمليه
التكوين الفهم الفهم الاشياء والوجود
والذاتيه
الوقت الى اليوم لم يعد من الممكن ان نميز
ما بينهما عقلاني مئه في المئه بشكل جذري
عن ما هو ادراكي حسي الى اخره ولكن ما
نلاحظه
هذه المؤثرات الكبرى التي
منها الصوره ومنها مغسله في انواعها الصور
همم التي تجعل الانسان همم
همم بصدى دي ضياعي نوع من انواع القوه
الادراكيه التي يمتلكها ازاءها في علاقته
بالواقع وبما يعرض عليه من صور وايضا اا
هناك نوع من انواع عناصر اضعاف درجه
انتباه انتباه لما يجري حوالينا
ولما هو اساسي وما هو ثانوي وما هو فرعيه
وبالتالي اصبحت الامور امام نافع نوع من
انواع الاختلاط التي همم للحواس في هذا
دور بقدر مال عقل ايضا وقدراته على على
اقتناهي
الخلفيات وما يتوي داخل الصور وداخل
الكلام وداخل الاصوات من معانيه ومن
الرسائل طيب همم تركز في قصته في الكتاب
صور الوجول عن العلاقه بين السينما
والفلسفه تقارب السينما ليس كصناعه بقدر
ما تكثيف لابعاد الوجود اذا كنت فاهم جيدا
مج- اا ما في الكتاب لماذا سينما وهل
تعتبر انك ضعف في ااا قراءه ما تحمله
السينما من رسائل العربيه
اولا السينما موضوع بقدر ما هو همم فضاء
للترفيه والتسليه
ولنسيان الداج حينما ندخل همم الفيلم لكي
نكتشف حكايات وروايات وربما لكي نتماها مع
ابطال ومع شخصيات الذين يتحولون الى هجوم
بقدر ما هي هكذا والدور بقدر ما انها اكبر
اختراع تقني لصناعه الروايات في القرن
العشرين وبالتالي فهي اكبر اكتشاف ابداعي
انتشر على نطاق واسع يشاهده من الناس
سينما اذا اعتبرناها فن
لا يضاهها اي فن اخر وبالتالي فانها قريبه
من الشعوب وتقرب الشعوب وتسمح لشعوب
بمعرفتك
نحن لا نعرف كثيرا لكن في الوقت نفسه
للانتاج مركز في هذا الموضوع
استاذ الاحمر لانه موضوع يندرج توزيع
الدولي لانتاج الصور
في الشمال افريقيا او في العالم العربي
انتاجنا بسيط ومتواضع جدا
في امريكا او في الهند او حتى في نيجيريا
انت تعرف بان السينما نيجيريا اكبر من
ناحيه الكميه سينما في العالم بعد الهند
وبعد همم امريكا الى امريكا
الاشياء بسيطه
ثانوي
بالدرجه الاولى نحن في وضعيات الاستهلاك
اكثر نحن في مجال ال- ال- الانتاج حينما
كانت السينما المصريه سينما حقيقيه وكانت
حقيقيه ولها انتشار عربي واسع جدا كان
درجه كبيره جدا ما بين تفاعل المجتمعات
العربيه مع الانتاج المصري ولكن حينما
تراجعات اصبحنا الى حد ما يتامى الانتاج
البصري هل هي تشكل نوع من همم نموذج حياه
ما زالت حتى اليوم
طبعا الان صحيح انه هناك تحولات تقنيه
ومؤسسيه وماليه كبرى اكثر السينما بها
منها دخول التلفزيون بشكل كبير على كبيره
على الانتاج سليمان
تغير تماما وهي بصدد تغيير تماما المنطق
الانتاج والمنطق تصور ومنطق اخراج لانه
حينما تنظر الى بعض منصات التي قواعد
معينه على المخرجين على المخرجين وعلى
طريقه التقطير وعلاق طريقه ترتيب لقطات
الى اخره انت تتساءل الى اي حد ذلك التلك
الهوامش الكبرى التي كانت للمخرج من ناحيه
الابداعيه هل مازالت ستضمن في المستقبل
ولمنطقها التي تفرضها على الناس الذين
يشتغلونها هل ترى ان هي لا تحمل اليوم
الفلسفه بشكل جديد مثلا شو السينما تحمل
الفلسفه بشكل جديد تقدمها بشكل جديد
السينما اولا مرتبطه بمن يبدعها
والسينمات سيارات واتجاهات والمدارس
على قوه كبيره على طرح الاسئله من خلال
العده السينمائيه
الجسد وفي طرق تقديم هذا الانسان المعاصر
في زمانه في مكانه في المجتمع وفي ثقافه
معينه السينما برهانات
الماضي الى اليوم على قدره الكبيره على
كشف الوجود على اظهار الواقع على الكشف عن
تناقضات الانسان وعن مختلفت مظهرات هذا
همم هذه الحياه الانسانيه سواء كانت على
سبيل المعاناه او الالم وليس به الفرح او
التطلع الى اخره السينما لها تمتلك اذا
اخذنا بعض المخرجين الذين عرفوا كيف
ينظفون هذه العده من اجل السياقه اسئله
كبرى حول الوجود الانساني انها بالفعل
تمتلك هذه القوه
لا متابعه ومواكبات المسارات الانسانيه
المختلفه داخل المجتمعات المختلفه وهل ترى
هناك ضعف لاهتمام المثقف العربي بظاهره
السينما
نستعرض كتابات المفكرين العرب الكبار
الذين اثروا في الثقافه العربيه المعاص
ره نجد منهم من اهتم بالسينما باعتبارها
مجال الفني
ويعلق عليها
ولكن قليل من المفكر العربي الكبار الذين
سينما
الغربي
اللهم الا بعض النقاد الكبار العرب الذين
تجدهم يهتمون الى ما تعبر عنه الافلام
المغربيه العربيه والمغربيه وغيرها من
القضايا الكبرى التي يعانيها ان شاء الله
العربي
ولذلك نوع من انواع التقصير داخل في اوساط
المتقافيه العرب في علاقتهم
في هذا الكتاب وفي كتب اخرى دكتور
حاولت دي مجرد محاولات محاولات ان مساله
سينما وغير سينما اي مساله الصوره يبدو
انه في الفكر الفلسفي في الفكر لابد من ان
نعطيه ما يلزم من الاهتمام بالبحث من
التفكير ومن التاليف وايضا نشر هذه
الافكار على الناس حتى
يتمكنون من الصناره بان هذا رهام كبير
وموضوع يستحق ان يكون ايضا من الموضوعات
الكبرى للفكر العربي المعاصر شكرا لك
دكتور افايه على المشاركه في محاور وذكر
بعنوان الكتاب الاخير صور الوجود في
السينما والفلسفه شكرا شكرا
لكم مشاهدينا والى اللقاء في حلقه جديده
من